vous propose de revenir un petit peu sur
le déroulé des événements d'aujourd'hui
qui répond à un protocole extrêmement
minutieux dans un premier temps c'est le
ministre la défense sergueï choïgou qui
est sorti du kremlin qui se trouve juste
à ma droite dans une limousine
décapotable qui a passé en revue les
troupes stationnées au milieu de la
place rouge
c'est ensuite vladimir poutine qui a
pris la parole il a ainsi rappelé que
cette date du 24 juin n'a pas été adopté
par défaut pour remplacer celle du 9 mai
car le 24 juin 1945 figurer ici le
premier défilé de la victoire les
soldats qui revenait tout juste du front
du front des batailles de moscou de
leningrad ou encore de la bataille de
berlin sont venus directement sur cette
plage rouge sur cette place rouge pour
déposer les étendards ennemis pour les
jeter au sol au pied du mausolée de
lénine au pied du kremlin je vous
propose d'écouter vladimir poutine qui
évoque le sacrifice de tous ceux qui se
sont battus pour défendre cette nation
nous garderont toujours en mémoire que
c'est le peuple soviétique a vaincu le
nazisme annales des millions de
personnes d'ethnie déchirante de toutes
les républiques de l'union soviétique
sur le front dans les arrières dans les
sections de partisans se sont battus
pour défendre avec courage et unité leur
terre natale
ils ont poursuivi ce combat et ils sont
libérés les pays occupés par les nazis
dans toute l'europe
ils ont sauvé du nazisme et de son
idéologie mortifère l'allemagne et il
est impossible de d'imaginer ce que
serait devenu le monde
si l'armée rouge n'était pas venu au
secours de la paix à la suite de
l'intervention du président russe la
parade militaire en tant que tel a pu
commencer ce sont pas moins de treize
mille soldats en grande majorité des
soldats russes certains portant même
l'uniforme de la grande guerre
patriotique qui ont défilé sur cette
place rouge 13
délégations étrangères ont également
participé des délégations venant d'inde
de chine du kirghizstan l'ouzbékistan ou
d'objets le russie pour n'en citer que
quelques-unes
ensuite cela a été le tour des véhicules
blindés et autres pièces d'aciéries de
défiler sur cette place rouge et je peux
vous dire de là où nous avons assisté à
cette parade le vacarme était
véritablement assourdissant et enfin
pour terminer en apothéose le volet
aérien de cette parade ce sont pas moins
de 75 appareils hélicoptères avions de
chasse et autres bombardiers qui se sont
succédé pour survoler sur cette place
rouge alors cette année
pas de marche du régiment immortels
comme c'est normalement le cas à la
suite des parades militaires
cet événement a été repoussée au 26
juillet prochain mais par contre ce soir
à 23 heures il y aura bien le grand feu
d'artifice pour célébrer ce jour de la
victoire